- My name is Tracy Rabin.
And I'm Director of the
Office of Global Health
in the Department of Internal Medicine
at the Yale School of Medicine.
I'm also the co-director of the
YIGH Global Health Ethics Program.
And it is truly an honor today to be able
to introduce you to the featured speaker
for our very special YIGH
event Dr. Olusoji Adeyi.
Dr. Adeyi's career accomplishments
are truly impressive.
Before I share a bit of his background.
I wanna summarize by saying that if
the true measure of our successes are the
number of lives that have been changed for
the better because of one's efforts,
both direct and indirect,
then he is among our times most eminent.
Dr. Adeyi is currently the President
of Resilient Health Systems,
a Washington DC based Policy Analysis
and Advisory Services Firm.
And he's also a Senior Associate at
the Johns Hopkins Bloomberg
School of Public Health.
Over the course of his
more than 30 year career,
focusing on global health policy,
he has held leadership positions with
the World Bank,
World Health Organization,
UNAIDS, the Nigerian
Federal Ministry of Health.
And was the founding director of
the Affordable Medicines Facility Malaria,
a public private partnership posted by
the Global Fund to fight AIDS,
tuberculosis and malaria.
With a focus on improving the structure
and function of health systems,
these positions have allowed him truly to
touch every region of the world.
Born in Nigeria, Dr. Adeyi earned his
Bachelor's in Medical Degrees from the
University of Ife and
subsequently received
a Master of Community Health from the
Liverpool School of Tropical Medicine,
a Master of Business Administration
from Imperial College
London, University of London.
And ultimately his Doctor
of Public Health from
the Johns Hopkins University.
When we spoke a few weeks ago,
he shared that it was his early work
as a physician that motivated him to
pursue additional training and to set off
on this very unique journey.
In that role he had
the personal experience
of seeing the devastating impact that
financial policies influenced by national
priorities and international donors
had on patients and the health system.
And as he told me I
wanted to be in a position
to influence policy rather than
being on the receiving end.
Along those lines he had also shared
the perspective that it's important for
those of us who seek global health careers
to embark on this journey for reasons
that are personally meaningful.
As this is what will stiffen the spine
and keep us moving forward in
the face of adversity.
I am certain that this sense of purpose
will come through in today's conversation.
And I look forward to the other lessons
that he has to share with us.
Dr. Adeyi, thank you so much
for joining us here today.
I'll turn the podium over now to
the moderator for today's Q&A session.
My Yale School of Public Health colleague,
Raphael Perez-Escamilla,
Professor of Public Health
and Director of the Office
of Public Health Practice
and the Global Health Concentration.
Looking forward to a
very robust conversation.
- Thank you so very much, Tracey
for your kind introduction and Olusoji,
what an honor to be able to serve as a
host today for you to
share with our audience
why did you decide to take the somewhat
painful step of writing a book to actually
share your experiences in global health?
What is the niche that
you tried to position
your book when you decided to write it?
- Thank you very much, Tracey for your
kind introduction and
Raphael and your team
for this opportunity to
have this conversation.
You refer to the process of
writing the book as painful.
That's true.
I think there were two
other dimensions to it.
One is it was actually a joy
because it was so
instructive writing the book.
And this is the book I
wish I had when I was 25.
And I've written it
several times in my mind,
but I finally had an
opportunity to put it on paper.
So what is the motivation behind the book?
The ultimate motivation is for those of us
who are engaged in public health,
whether as policy makers,
as analysts,
as physicians
or influencers,
that we step back reexamine the roots
of global health take stock of
what has worked well
and importantly, honestly, appraise why
it is so unhappy today,
why global health is so unhappy.
But that we do so not because we want to
then slump into negativity
that nothing can ever improve.
Also we do so with a
renewed sense of purpose
and clear eyed optimism that
we can make it better.
That is the ultimate purpose of the book.
And which is why my favorite sentence
in the book is actually the
last sentence in the book.
Which says, "A brighter
future is possible."
- Thank you very much Olusoji.
And I do want to share with you
and the audience that I worked
for three years in your beautiful
country of Nigeria in the State of Kaduna
with maternal infant
and young child feeding project.
And through that project I learned
on the one hand how complex Nigeria was
and is from political economic systems,
healthcare systems, the
patient systems point of view.
But at the same time I also learned about
the incredibly rich culture
and traditions
and quite frankly
experiences that the country
has had over many, many
decades now trying to
improve a number of healthcare outcomes
that are not only unique to Nigeria,
but also to the rest of the world.
So can you tell us a little bit about how
having been born raised in Nigeria
actually ended up informing
your decision to end up working in
the field of global health
to do it from a capacity
building perspective?
And lastly, what have you learned from
your own experience with regards to the
legacy of colonialism and neocolonialism
on current global health inequities.
- Thanks Rafael and now that I know
you are my fellow Nigerian,
I think one of these days you and I should
get together and share
a glass of palm wine,
which I'm sure you had when
you were in the country.
But on the topic at hand in hindsight
it's all very clear now in hindsight.
Much of what I do is influenced by
my own early experiences
and some form the
formative years in Nigeria,
excuse me.
My mother is a retired business woman.
My father was a nurse.
So I saw quite a few cases
that he treated early on.
And there's one that sticks in my mind.
He was extracting Guinea
worm from somebody's leg.
And that was quite impressive for a
five or six year old to witness.
But in the larger social context,
I grew up in a society with its
own very powerful narrative.
I was born in Oyo which is the capital of
an old empire that predated many of
the countries we're talking about.
It predated the United
States, for example.
And Oyo is called the land of
Shango, the God of thunder.
We had a very strong sense
of our own social identity.
I also did my undergraduate
years in Nigeria.
And I went to medical school there too.
And what I experienced there was
the part of an of education
and the stresses that poverty can put on
those who cannot afford the
healthcare that they need.
I think that was a very searing experience
to witness as a young physician
when I witnessed that,
but also come from a background in which
we were taught from day one,
that you have to do something about
the world around you.
You're not just gonna complain about it.
So I opted to go into public health policy
as a result of that.
Well, when I look back now,
I think two or three
things stand out to me,
the importance of a sense of purpose.
This is for positive reasons
because it keeps us going.
It keeps us going on a day to day basis.
It also makes us more resilient to
the various ups and
downs that we experience
in the cause of the
career in global health.
The second one is to
pay extra attention to
the realities of people with whom we work
in low and lower middle income countries.
They have their own narratives.
They may not have studied epidemiology
and biostatistics
and health economics.
And so some of the things they do
and some of the ways they go about things
may not make sense to somebody
who has just parachuted in
from the global north.
But if one has a certain
degree of humility
and a willingness to learn,
then it becomes possible to
understand their reality.
It becomes possible to engage with them
in a very effective way.
And it becomes possible for the
programs on which we work,
the analysis that we do to actually
have a multiplier effect.
- Thank you, Olusoji.
And as part of the subtitle of your book
you list investing amid pandemics
denial of evidence and neo dependency.
Can you talk to us a little bit about
what do you mean by denial of evidence
as well as neo dependency
and why are those important to
understand and address?
- Thank you, Rafael.
In our profession,
in public health policy
one of the tenants is to rigorously base
our recommendations and our programs
on scientific analysis.
Of course you adapt
from country to country
and even within countries so as to be
viable during implementation.
And I think this is great.
It's central to what we do it's central
to our professional credibility.
However, if you look at the world
around us in global health,
that premise does not always hold up.
So let me answer your question directly.
One of the things about which I've been
most impressed in my career is the extent
to which evidence is swept aside
when it does not meet the preferences
of powerful outdoors in global health.
There are many examples of those.
And I refer to a few in the book,
but the one that is really central
to the illustration in the book
is that of the United States Agency
for International Development, USAID
and the US President's
Malaria Initiative, USPMI.
This is concerning access
to malaria medicines
for people in low income countries
despite rigorous evaluation
of a pilot program.
That in fact the approach
taken was working
USAID and USPMI did everything they could
to derail that program.
They bullied any entity that did not
subscribe to their point of view.
And they successfully
bullied the global fund
to fight AIDS, TB and malaria into
discontinuing that program.
Now, I'm not telling you any State secret.
It just happens that I left that
enterprise so I had a front row seat
into what happened.
So this is an instance in which
USAID and USPMI simply obliterated a
program that was
demonstratively on the path
to saving many lives in low
and lower middle income countries,
because it does not conform
to their preferences.
And because if it worked,
my understanding, since it was
demonstrated to be working,
it was a threat to the way
USAID does its business,
which is to give hundreds of
millions of dollars contracts
to American based contractors.
And if that program were expanded
and institutionalized
as it should have been,
that will really put USAID's
business model in turmoil.
So that is a prime example
of denial of evidence
as you state, by the way,
that at the time that
program was evaluated,
it was probably the most rigorously
evaluated large program in global health
around that time.
Now on neo dependency,
let's be upfront about one item,
which is that colonialism
was extremely bad.
There's no other way to describe it.
Crimes against humanity were
committed by European powers
and by those who enslaved Africans,
there's no qualifying it, period.
And it is also true that
effects of colonialism
are still with us in
terms of the fact that
the colonized societies even though
they're now politically independent,
the wound endures in terms of their
social policies and the devastation that
was ricked over the years.
Having said that, my
proposition in the book
is that a greater problem,
a problem that is greater
than neocolonialism
and the lasting effect
of colonialism is the,
what I call neo dependency.
That's the dependency or
the perpetual dependency
of many countries in the
global south on the global north.
And this is manifested clearly,
but not only in the way foreign aid
is mediated by several institutions
and in the way those countries is
I see they really do not want to graduate
from being dependent on the global north.
And that if this is going
to be turned around,
then there needs to be
a fundamental change,
such that those countries become
more reliant on their own revenues,
on their own domestic resources.
And that they demonstrate what I will call
increasingly self financed assertiveness.
That really is the core of it.
So while the perennial the bad
effects of colonialism endure,
the central problem as I understand it is
actually that of neo dependence.
And that leads to several
recommendations in the book.
- Thank you very much Olusoji.
And I do want to ask the audience
to please take opportunity of
take this opportunity to
engage with Dr. Olusoji
on some questions and answers based on
these very thought provoking
and important statements that he's making.
So.
- [Tracey] Rafael, we do have
one question that came in.
- Please, please.
- [Tracey] And the question is
how do we as students and staff at Yale
or other powerful institutions
in the global north work advocate in work
in mitigating the negative effects
of neocolonialism and global health?
- Wow, that's a trillion dollar
question and a great one.
I think before advocating my sense of it
is to be very deeply aware of
the narrative around us
and how those effects of
neocolonialism modulated in real life.
So it starts with the
courses in those schools.
My sense is that while epidemiology
and biostatistics
and the behavioral sciences
and health economics remain central
and core to a rigorous curriculum
in public health, for example.
It is important to pay equally
serious attention to political analysis,
to the political economy of global health,
and to what I will call
influencing policies
and enabling change so that we do not go
into a highly political situation
with purely technocratic tools that assume
that if we just get our regressions right
then everything will fall in place.
That's the first one.
The second step is taking the time
and making a serious effort to understand
the social political narrative
and the social political realities
of the countries in which
we seek to operate.
Let me share an example
that is in the book.
In this book, Global Health In Practice.
I lived in Ethiopia many years ago
as a young professional working with
the World Health Organization.
And I was there during the war
that ended in 1991.
One of the things that I observed
was that many, very
senior technical experts
who had been trained in really high class,
high quality schools of the likes
of Yale and all the others.
They will come into the country
and a number of them will look at
their counterparts and they will see
this stereotypical, poor citizen
of a poor country,
or poor official,
an official of a poor
country that needed help.
And they're promptly proceeded to
prescribe solutions to those officials.
Now they were doing so with the best
of technical or technocratic intentions,
if I may use that phrase,
the problem was it did not fit the
narrative of those officials
because the officials looked in the mirror
and they saw the descendants of those
who won the battle of Adwa
when the Ethiopians defeated Italians.
And this was no in addition to that,
they remember the association between the
Queen of Sheba and King Solomon.
So when they looked in the mirror,
they saw the descendants of
a very proud people.
And you can just imagine how these
two narratives collided.
And that limited the effectiveness
of those Europeans
and North Americans to whom I referred.
So taking the time to truly understand
the narrative and the
social political dynamics
of the people with whom
we are engaging is key.
A third one is to be very clear
in terms of what we're optimizing for.
If we're optimizing for
a small pilot project
to demonstrate effect in a population
of 500 people or 5,000 people
in one sub district it's
a legitimate thing to do.
But if our aim is to engage with
and influence what happens all across
a very large country like Pakistan
or Democratic Republic of Congo,
or all of Nicaragua,
just to say three examples from
different parts of the world,
then we need to understand that we are
engaged in an enterprise that is
substantially political
and proceed as such.
- Thank you very much Olusoji.
And we're doing our best at the
Yale school of Public Health
to actually update or develop new courses
to very strongly emphasize the points
that you just made about how yes
small scale efficacy trials
or studies are important,
but the ability to transfer that crucial
knowledge for the survival
and healthy development of human beings
into large scale sustainable operations
is another ballgame.
And really requires a deep understanding
of the history,
the political,
the economic,
the social systems in the countries.
And so I found very rapidly
in Kaduna in Nigeria,
and really understanding how powerful
the community structures are.
And how impossible it is to scale up
anything if there is no support from
the community leaders for those projects
to end up being implemented
successfully on the ground.
So, I really want to urge the audience to
read this very important book
on global health practice
because it really comes from what we,
I like to call a huge global health
practice scholar that has been there,
has done that and has been able to
look at the global health challenges
from many different angles
over several decades.
So please keep on sharing with us
your very insightful questions.
So moving on to the next
part of the discussion.
Olusoji as you know given the context
of the uncertainty with
the COVID 19 pandemic,
the likelihood that it's
not going to be the last
probably at least in my lifetime,
some of our students even our faculty
are a little bit anxious about
how the future jobs in global health
are going to look like.
Which are the skills that the future
global health professionals should have
to be successful doing their work.
So can you share with us the contributions
from your excellent book towards
institutions like Yale
to convey to the faculty,
to the students in terms of what
they should be focusing
on to really strive
to become really key global health
practitioners moving forward?
- Thanks Rafael.
I think the probably the single most
important question to ask oneself is
how can I be most useful?
And that may sound so obvious,
but I think a failure to closely reflect
on that question might lead
to a lot of frustration.
So if one approaches it from
the point of being useful,
then it means go where the problems are.
And be equipped with the tools to
help better understand those problems
and to help formulate workable solutions
to those problems even if they are not
the ideal solutions from a purely
theoretical point of view.
So let's compact this.
In terms of being useful,
perhaps because of the COVID 19 pandemic
and the subsequent
attention to global health
for people younger
colleagues who are about to
go into the field I would say you are
actually very fortunate
because you don't have
to explain to anybody
what public health is,
or you don't have to
explain to most people
what public health is or
why it is so important.
Now everybody gets it, okay.
In order to be useful
I think one also needs
to figure out which niche to occupy
or to seek to occupy initially.
So is it to be an analyst helping to
better understand the scale,
the dynamics of health problems.
Is it to be primarily a doer?
And I'm not suggesting that those are
very different, they're intertwined.
In which case it'll make sense to seek
opportunities in entities,
implementing programs in
challenging situations.
And to go with the intention of learning.
Or is it to be primarily
in an advocacy position?
Again, that's not separate from
being an analyst or a doer.
I'm just trying to simplify
and that's okay too.
And then it means understanding whether
one is seeking to be an analyst
in terms of bearing witness,
which has its place,
or whether I want seek to go beyond
bearing witness and nudging,
rich and powerful entities to do better
by the developing countries or nudging
the rulers of developing countries to
do better by their own societies.
One final note on that is overarching
Charles Houston, who was the
Professor of Thurgood Marshall
at the Howard University Law School,
which is just a mile from where
I'm speaking in Washington DC,
had an injunction for his students.
And he said it was not
sufficient to be a lawyer
they also had to be social engineers.
Otherwise they were just being parasites.
I think that applies to people in
global public health, too.
In different ways it's important to have
the mindset of a social engineer
an analytically rigorous social engineer.
Otherwise one might
unwittingly become a parasite.
So in some, the future is bright
for those entering global health.
There are just so many challenges
waiting to be tackled
and please go forth and be useful.
- Thank you so very much for
such an inspiring answer.
And Abel Galetta is also asking,
given the complex skills essentially
that are needed here to succeed
in the field of global health.
How do you overcome the challenges
that inevitably you are going to find
as an early career professional?
What did you do to overcome
those challenge yourself?
What words of wisdom your book
has to offer to Abel and colleagues?
- I really, I really
appreciate your question.
This is Abel Galetta if I'm
looking at the chat box.
Great question.
I think it's important
to have good mentors
because when you're starting out
there are many things that are just so new
and they can be confusing,
and sometimes you might struggle with
how to prioritize and what to filter out.
So having a mentor or a set of mentors
in my view is really important.
A second one is approaching global health
or the mindset that every obstacle is an
opportunity to learn
and get better and grow.
I think those two are
really they are fundamental.
Yeah, those are the two key ones
that I would say early on finding,
having good mentors and
approaching obstacles
from the perspective of learning.
I think those are really,
those are critical.
- Yes, thank you Olusoji very much.
And then linking this somewhat to
the previous statement that you made about
the US Agency of
International Development,
which is, as we know
is not unique to USAID
it's a very common situation with
international aid
agencies and the fact that
they all have their agendas,
their priorities, and sometimes
from almost overnight,
they change and countries that are
being affected by huge problems
and working with them for decades,
do not have a say on when and how
those pivot points happen.
So several of my students
have asked me in the past
is there any hope that I can actually work
for an agency like that and change it
from the inside out?
If I choose not to work in an agency
like that then where am I going to work?
Where am I going to be
able to make a difference?
And I get a very well your important point
about advocacy and
grassroots work and so on,
but also in the context that
financial resources are needed as well
to engage in large scale
programming and so on.
And what would you advise our students
regarding the sense of hopelessness that
some of them have that it's very
difficult would be almost impossible to
change the way the key
agencies are governed,
the structures that they have
and somewhat arbitrary way in which that
they follow to make decision.
- Yeah, Rafael I would say they
are very complex institutions.
And within that complexities there are
opportunities for
professionals who are rigorous,
who are discerning and who are committed
to making a difference.
So even for younger members or staff,
it means being very credible in ones
own analytical work and developing a way
of engaging with more senior people in the
institutions to inform their thinking
and to change the way
they look at problems.
And if that change means a 25% improvement
over what the world have done before,
that's a win to start with.
But at that stage for the
entry level professionals,
it means their span of control
is relatively narrow, that's true.
But over time you get a much broader
and increasingly a bigger span of control.
And therefore the scope
to influence decisions
and influence policies
becomes even larger.
So I can share a few examples with you.
There's a chapter on Russia in the book.
And yes, I led the team
that did that turnaround.
I also had a vice president at the time
for the region who was supportive
of the effort that we made.
So that's a positive aspect.
And there were several other aspects
in which I was involved,
both analytical work and
program implementation
and financing, et cetera.
So it is not a case of black or white that
institutions are absolutely ill deemable.
I think it's the case
that they're very complex.
And within that complexity
there are opportunities
for public health professionals to
make a serious difference.
Having said that in terms
of the macro system,
realigning the macro system,
et cetera, et cetera.
Well, that is beyond the purview of any
particular individual in global health
or agriculture or transportation,
whichever sector you primarily work in.
That becomes a political question
in terms of the global
financial architecture.
And that is part of the point in the book.
So please, if you are wondering,
is it a hopeless task to work with
or in those large agencies, like WHO,
the World Bank, et cetera, et cetera.
No, it is not.
There are vast opportunities there
and I will seriously encourage you
to seize those opportunities.
- Thank you very much Olusoji.
And for the audience, please,
if you want to share with Olusoji
any personal experiences working for
agencies or in the field,
your academic institutions and so on,
and what have you learned from them
we would very much welcome
your sharing of those experiences.
So I want to move on now towards
the last phase of our conversation,
which is related to how
to maintain initiatives,
how to maintain traction,
how to ensure that the
relatively few programs
that have been successfully scaled up
across countries essentially keep on going
and they don't fall back to the
chaos that was there before they emerged.
So in terms of sustainability of programs,
what lessons does your work offers to us?
- A great question.
And perhaps is the perennial question.
In my experience, I think programs become
sustainable on multiple dimensions.
Quite often when we talk
about sustainability,
we're talking about
financial sustainability
and technical sustainability,
both of which are highly important.
There is another dimension,
which is political sustainability.
And for the median leader,
a program is sustainable
when the perceived
political benefits of that program
of continuing that program
or enlarging it when they outweigh
the political risks of not continuing it.
Which is why it is very important for
the political leaders in societies to
be directly engaged in and to own
large programs in their own countries.
It's also very important for the citizens
of those societies to see and feel
the benefits of those programs.
If the benefits of a program are obscure
well, there's unlikely to be much
social mobilization behind it,
but if they're visible they're actually
communicated to the public
and the successive government know that
these programs are actually
delivering good things.
Then they're more likely to at least
make an effort to continue those programs.
There's another there's a little dimension
that I would like to
draw our attention to.
And this is the compared to what question.
So if you engage in a large program
and just for discussion sake,
let's just say the success rate before
you went in was 10%
and you are able to take it to 60%.
Obviously that's not perfect, okay.
You really want to hit
something much higher.
All of that things being equal.
I think it is wise to celebrate
that improvement from 10 to 60%.
And then seek to take it to 70%.
But sometimes in global public health,
I have seen situations in which if
it cannot go from 10% to a 100%
then you have many advocates saying,
"Okay, it's a failure, it's bad."
So it's a binary situation,
which is just so self-defeating.
So again, for all of us
going into this field
or those who are there
and seeking to make
even more improvements,
let's keep this in mind.
The compared to what question,
because quite often the counterfactual
is not utopian perfection.
The counterfactual is exactly something
that is a really bad situation.
So if it's getting better celebrate it,
don't be complacent.
Don't be satisfied.
Celebrate that success.
And just keep pushing ahead.
Don't just throw it all away
because you cannot achieve
immediate perfection.
- Absolutely Olusoji couldn't,
well, I say absolutely.
(speaker laughing)
I myself, my experience
I couldn't agree more
because I really think that
that goes back to your point of the
importance of understanding that
complex causes behind these problems.
Many of which have been
with us for centuries.
And that we need to be realistic as to
what is a temporary solution.
What is a short term technical solution?
What at the end of the day would be
a real long term solution.
So if everybody's contributing
in a coordinated way,
I think with their 10 cents, so to speak,
to improve them it reaches a point where
those improvements are not attributed
and cannot be discounted.
So Pranuv Savanur has a very
thoughtful question for you.
So how can we build a sustained,
a non partisan political
will and commitment
for global health financing.
And he has in mind the
upcoming funding renewals
for programs like the global fund Gavi,
the World Health Organization
and so on how to separate politics from
the true mission of global health.
As a way of understand this question.
- Yeah, great question Pranuv.
First, politics cannot
be separated from it.
I think what can probably be
separated from it or what we should make
an effort to separate
from it is toxic politics.
Now, on the substance of the question,
I think for entities like Gavi
and the Global Fund the
real challenge as I see it
is how they will replenish to transition
and exit from what they're currently doing
in the way they're currently doing it.
So what will it take, for example,
such that eight years from now
seeing the year 2030,
the countries themselves are
the dominance financiers of those
basic health commodities
and of those basic health services
that Gavi and the Global Fund
disproportionately financed today.
So if you take a specific,
just take a specific example,
let's just zero in on malaria.
Last year, WHO recommended widespread use
of the RTS,S malaria vaccine.
The first time it's done that for
a malaria vaccine on a large scale.
And normally one will expect that
since this disease has been around for
millennia and is such a big problem,
the leaders of the countries will lead
and commit to funding the purchase of
those vaccines
predominantly by themselves.
Instead, what happened
was that Gavi announced
that it was going to commit,
I think about 156 million over the
next few years to those vaccines.
Now for is a child who
gets that vaccine in Zambia
or Liberia or wherever,
is that a bad thing?
No, it's a good thing.
The problem is the following,
Gavi was substituting itself again
for the leadership domestic leadership
in those countries.
And that was very poor judgment
on the part of Gavi, okay.
Still on malaria.
The very last estimate from the
World Malaria Report
published by WHO indicate
that two thirds of the expenditures
of malaria control and elimination
come from external sources.
That's two thirds, 67%.
So this needs to change cannot have
a situation where permanently there is
dependency on external financiers.
So for replenishment,
it should be replenishment for transition.
Not replenishment for self perpetuation.
That's the real key here that is
that I really want to,
that I really wanna have on.
So that applies to Global Fund and Gavi.
As for WHO I really am not convinced
that a replenishment model is
the right way to finance WHO
is the central health leadership agency,
the technical normative agency as well.
And it seems to me that having that
core financing sorted out is key.
I don't think that also means WHO
should be responsible
for everything or try
to do everything under the sun in health.
It does not mean WHO has to attend
every single meeting in
every single village on health.
So there's a case to be made for
concentrating the effort on WHO
on some core functions
and for funding them well
from through assess contribution to
the regular budget not
extra budgetary allocation.
Back to you Rafael.
- Yes, wow I think we could stay here for
three hours speaking with you.
What an engaging and
thoughtful conversation.
And I feel like really everyone
should read Olusoji's book.
Not many people have the
very, very holistic experience
that he has in global health.
Sumaira Barsada wants to thank you
very much for your talk.
She finds it very inspiring.
She just went to Amazon
and order your book
so that you know and she
can't wait to read it.
So I'm very, very glad
Sumaira that you got inspired
to do that during this conversation.
And I'm sure Olusoji will be very happy
to send your book when you get it.
We can easily arranged for that I think.
So, Olusoji to wrap up the
conversation on my end.
I really get your very
central message here.
It's loud and clear.
Unless governments end
up being empowered to own
the systems, the structures,
the infrastructure that
is needed to improve
public health within their countries
and to do so with equity
following human rights principles,
social justice principles,
and so on is very
difficult to actually see
how improvement can be
made on a global level.
We know that oftentimes there is this
tension between governments feeling
oh NGOs know how to do it,
they're really great at doing it
have them do it.
NGOs saying, we cannot do
this on a national scale.
We cannot keep this sustainable.
And oftentimes to me becomes
an absurd either or argument.
I really think that there is a
very special place for NGOs as part of
a new global health governance system.
But at the same time, there is absolutely
no reason why they cannot be part of
a government strategy
when the government's own
the programs, the policies
and so on to keep on working together.
So I mean, do you agree with that or not?
And what can be done to improve that?
A very, very interesting dynamic that
I think needs to be addressed to improve
much more public health across the globe.
- Yeah, Rafael I think you
touch on an important point.
There is no viable
substitute in the medium term
for a responsible government
that leads its own,
that leads policies within its own country
and walks across sectors
within its own country.
And that includes financing of course.
But there is a difference between
public financing on the one hand
and public delivery on the other hand.
So it's entirely possible.
Most systems are mixed, anyway.
It's entirely possible for most of
the expenditure in a country,
Most of the health expenditure in
a country to be to be publicly financed,
but for services to be delivered by
a combination of public facilities,
not for profit NGO
facilities, for example.
And for profit facilities who might be
contracted by government
to deliver those services
or contracted by a health insurance agency
to deliver those services.
And there is a serious
role for civil society
to play in that the NGOs and the CSOs,
if one wants to delineate both in terms of
keeping government honest,
if I may use that expression,
mobilizing the society
and shining the light
in otherwise dark areas.
But the NGOs and CFOs in my understanding
do not substitute for those
core governance policy
and policy translation functions that can
only be done by government.
And I will even go
further and say one thing.
In my experience both
the country based NGOs
and the international NGOs in
different places have made really
serious contributions to
health service delivery,
including in some very
hard to reach places.
At the same time it is the case that
some of the northern NGOs,
not all of them,
some of them sometimes unwittingly perhaps
substitute try to substitute themselves
for the government of those countries.
So they don't like
international organizations
to dictate policies to countries.
And they're right.
International organizations should not
dictate policies to the countries.
But in my experience,
quite a few of those NGOs
will like international organizations to
dictate the NGOs preferences
to the countries.
And that needs to stop.
In addition to that, quite a few of those
international organizations
do the countries
a disservice when they blame international
financing institutions for everything
because that infantalizes the governments
of those low and lower
middle income countries.
It's as if the governments
cannot think for themselves,
they cannot make decisions for themselves.
And it becomes very convenient to
just blame everything on outsiders.
So in that regard I think quite a few of
the large northern NGOs need
to do some introspection.
And avoid a situation
in which they position
themselves as if they are the legitimate
representatives of large populations,
those light populations in low
and lower middle income countries.
They're not.
And they cannot substitute
for those people.
I also wanna thank our colleagues who have
sent text messages, I think Shidrak also,
thanks for getting the book.
And I look forward to
engaging with you all.
Please feel free to join me on Twitter.
Back to you Rafael.
- And if I can squeeze
in one last question.
- [Olusoji] Please.
- And I apologize for those that
I cannot ask your questions.
But I think this is a
wonderful one to wrap
this conversation up.
And it comes from Avicii Ijasa
and it is about what does a future hold
for healthcare systems.
At the end of the day,
he asks if future states
in Sub-Saharan Africa currently almost
no country meets the World
Bank and WHO benchmarks
for universal health coverage
following the SDG 2030.
And in that context of
what has just happened
or is happening with COVID 19,
what is the future for healthcare systems
strengthening or for that agenda?
- It's a great question
on which to wrap up.
I agree with you.
I think the COVID 19 has been a clarifier.
Or it is the clarifier.
It's not yet over and it's brought a lot
of stress on societies.
On the positive side
it has also made clear
the importance of self reliance by
countries of the global south
because what has happened during COVID
is you realize when COVID struck,
let's face it,
the message from the
global north was look,
you are on your own.
So what does this mean?
It means that global south
needs to face its reality
when it comes to
universal health coverage,
Nobody is going to,
nobody from outside is
gonna solve it for them.
So my mind, the way to approach this is
what has already been described as
progressive universalism start with
an emphasis on a core
of essential services,
what some people refer to as
essential package of services
or essential health package.
And try to get this to
the whole population.
I think that is really key
in all our conversations.
So that's number one.
A second pillar of this in terms of
what of the how to finance it
is to move away from systems
in which many countries,
a large proportion of financing comes from
private out of pocket expenditures,
which is very regressive.
It's not equitable.
It causes financial hardship.
And to move more towards
publicly financed health systems.
But that also means doing better
in terms of domestic tax collection.
Many of the countries do very poorly
in terms of collecting their own taxes.
This are two of the pillars.
Not all, not all.
These are two of the pillars required to
make progress towards
universal health coverage.
There's the paper that I wrote about
four years ago with some colleagues,
we called it, The Economic
Transition of Health.
And I think we tried to unpack in that
we anticipated some of these
constraints that have now arisen.
Great question, Avicii
- Well, on that note, please join me in
a warmly thanking
Olusoji for the wonderful
contribution he has
made through his career
crystallized in his book
and for agreeing to have
this wonderful conversation with us today.
Thank you very, very much Olusoji.
(speaker clapping)
- Thank you, Raphael and colleagues.
Thanks everybody.
I really appreciate this
discussion with you.
Thank you.
- [Tracey] Thank you.